the saddest part of the state of the
union very few people have pointed this
out was this moment where
joe biden was trying desperately to name
he didn't have any accomplishments that
he could name so he just kept talking
about things in the future right he was
instead of talking about the state of
the union right now and as a result of
the last year of his leadership you just
say you know in the future we're going
to do this and next year we'll get we'll
cure cancer and five years from now
we're gonna have uh gumdrop candy
mountain that's gonna be really great uh
at one point though the democrats
started chanting
usa usa
[Applause]
autonomous
so
that was coming from the democrats the
usa usa usa and when i heard it it
struck me as so
foreign and artificial i said why why is
this so strange to me because i've never
heard democrats ever chant usa usa
neither have you even for our liberal
listeners out there our democrat
listeners out there i think if you're
being really honest with yourself you
can admit democrats don't do that
that's a republican thing to do
right because what democrats do is they
protest the american flag
they
teach in schools that america is a
racist bigoted terrible country that's
always been awful to black people and
minorities and indians and women and
every everyone who's not a straight
white man with blonde hair and blue eyes
america's just really been awful they
spread evil all around the world we're
just the worst country ever and we've
got nothing to be proud of
that's what the democrats teach okay but
what i think happened is the democrats
got their pollsters out there and they
know that this is a midterm election
year and they realized that hating
america doesn't play very well in peoria
and so they said okay we've got to
change this hey democrats and all the
members of congress have a script for
these things so they've got the little
script okay applaud here stand up here
chan i guess one of them was chant usa
usa just try do an impersonation of a
republican do an impersonation of a
conservative during the trump
administration standing up usa usa you
could see on the dais up there behind
joe biden you have nancy pelosi and
kamala harris and they're there for the
usa usa and they don't know what to do
they don't they're not chanting they're
kind of clapping in the rhythm there's
i've never heard this before
ah you usa you as it reminded me during
kovid
you remember andrew cuomo before he fell
from grace andrew cuomo was caught on
camera he said
you know
donald trump says make america great
again america was never that great
america was never that great
that's what he said damning line i think
he was speaking for a lot of democrats
don't forget andrew cuomo is considered
a moderate democrat so it wasn't even
some fringe line but they just believe
america was never that great
and then that got him into a little bit
of trouble and then he goes to the
democrat national convention and he
gives one of the speeches and he says
we're america strong we're
we're america america always does great
stuff where and you think buddy you
don't really believe that it rings
hollow and it rang hollow last night
the creepiest moment i thought of the
whole state of the union was at the very
end when joe biden started to ratchet up
the radicalism a little bit and he
started pushing his radical abortion law
to codify roe vs wade which very
possibly could be overturned in the new
supreme court session he wanted to
codify that into law so even if the
court gets rid of the fake
constitutional right to abortion it'll
still be a national law and every state
in the country is going to have to kill
babies and no state no people has the
right to say no we don't want to kill
babies in texas or tennessee so joe
biden was talking about that he came up
with a new
euphemism
for abortion
advancing liberty and justice also
requires
protecting the rights of women
the constitution right affirmed by roe v
wade standing president for half a
century is under attack as never before
if you want to go forward not backwards
we must protect access to health care
preserve a woman's right to choose and
continue to advance maternal health care
for all americans
maternal health care we've heard a lot
of euphemisms for abortion over the
years
we've heard reproductive rights ironic
because abortion stops reproduction and
it's not right we've heard women's
health care
which is very very vague right i call my
grandmother i say hey grandma how you
doing she she doesn't say well michael
you know my hip hurts and my friend died
and the car broke down but hey at least
i have my right to abortion right that's
not what all women mean by health quite
the opposite
but this was the first time i'd ever
heard this one and it's the most
ghoulish one of all
maternal health care today is ash
wednesday over a billion people will
start living different in some way maybe
that means giving up chocolate or
alcohol or whatever for a lot of people
lent is a time of finding the easiest
way to give something up but at the end
of those 40 days did that sacrifice
really make a difference this year there
is a new opportunity out there
especially for men that will actually
help you grow closer to god and become a
better man you may have heard me talk
about exodus 90. let me tell you about
exodus lent a 40-day journey that will
challenge you to dig a little deeper
this year here's how it works first over
the 40 days of lent men commit to daily
prayer setting aside a minimum of 20
minutes to spend with the lord each day
it includes scripture reading reflection
written to help men better understand to
grow in and live virtue
second
more than just giving up chocolate men
take up a range of disciplines and
sacrifices for the season of lent sweet
snacks social media all gone third men
commit to a fraternity of five to seven
men each week the fraternity meets to
pray together check in hold each other
accountable and encourage one another on
easter sunday you walk away with a new
and lasting understanding of what it
means to live a christian life chocolate
bunnies and all sign up now it's not too
late sign up now exodus 90.com
michael see the democrats use these
euphemisms for abortion because they
don't want to admit that abortion it
necessarily involves killing a baby so
they won't even acknowledge that the
baby's real most of the time they'll say
no it's just women's health oh it's just
a minor medical procedure it's just it's
reproductive rights
right the right
they'll equate it with contraception the
idea that you're not even you're you're
going to stop it before it even becomes
a baby
but
maternal health care
is acknowledging that the woman getting
an abortion is already a mother
maternal health care is acknowledging
that the baby really is a baby in the
fullest sense of the word you're calling
the woman getting an abortion mommy
and mommy is going to snuff out her
little baby
if joe biden has his way and mommies
aren't even going to have the right to
get together and pass laws in their
states to outlaw killing babies if joe
biden gets his way
that is some spooky stuff from allegedly
the moderate democrat from allegedly the
catholic joe biden
i'm a legend i'm you know i'm personally
pro-life but politically i'm pro-choice
he used to do that you remember that
that was a little song and dance that
democrats came up with decades ago to
get themselves out of that tight spot on
abortion especially catholic democrats
mario cuomo did it in new york but now
they've totally gotten rid of that and
joe biden doesn't believe a damn thing
that he pretends to believe in all he
cares about is
saying the things that are popular in
his party and maintaining power
so now he says yeah it's maternal health
care
yeah yeah it's a baby yeah you
pro-lifers you were right it's a baby
and we're coming for him spooky spooky
stuff and then the silliest line of the
night was when joe biden
said that what democrats support is not
defunding the police not abolishing the
police actually democrats want to fund
the police
proven strategies like community
violence interruption trusted messengers
breaking the cycle of violence and
trauma
giving young people some hope
we should all agree the answer is not to
defund the police
it's to fund the police
fund them
fund them yeah fund the that's what we
support we're democrats we support
funding the police
even though we just spent two years
actual not only threatening to defund
the police not only having aoc say
abolish the police means abolish the
police it doesn't mean move money around
it means you're actually going to get
rid of the police rashida talib ilhan
omar not just them but da's democrat
governors mayors all around the country
actually defunding the police that's why
we have an historic crime surge right
now you've got murders in particular
violent crime way way up over the last
years because of actual democrat
policies that were already implemented
and then joe biden gaslights everyone
says we support funding the police
no you don't no you don't like
prove it buster
well no and then all the democrats they
stand up there and they applaud they
haven't changed one iota of their policy
they haven't pushed for a tough on crime
bill in the congress those people who
are in that that room just there i
haven't seen a democrat tough on crime
bill anywhere in the country so it's
just a lie it just they realize that
voters around the country don't like it
that now that gang bangers are shooting
bullets through their windows and that
they know that democrats are directly
responsible for this and so they say
okay guys hey let's get us through
november we support funding the police
don't we no you don't it's just total bs
and then i'm not even that's all i'm
going to play of the of the state of the
union i can't bear i sat through it once
i don't need to sit through it again all
right i did i did my duty to you people
because i know that you didn't watch it
so i i sat there i took the slings and
arrows
it was a good way to get ready for this
penitential season i sat there and i did
it but i'm not watching it again the
first 10 to 20 minutes of it though
were not a state of the union address
the first 10 to 20 minutes were
a state of the putin address i don't did
he even mention america during the first
20 minutes i don't i don't think so i
was waiting for him i said it's the
state of the nato state of the european
union all he was talking about was
ukraine and he didn't offer any anything
productive on ukraine he didn't say
here's how we're going to end this war
here's how we're not going to escalate
and avoid world war 3. here's how here's
what we should have done differently
because very specific biden policies led
to this moment in ukraine as i covered
on the show some days ago
no he didn't talk about any of that he
just talked vaguely about this war in
ukraine and because the war in ukraine
is the best thing to happen to the biden
administration i'm damning with faint
praise he's failed on every single front
but it's the best thing that happened
previously the best thing that happened
to biden was kovid because he could
blame all of his problems on kovid but
then a lot of his predictions about kova
didn't come true a lot of his
prescriptions turned out to not work at
all and so kovit's no longer a positive
for him even in the polls the best thing
he can do now is say i'm a wartime
president i'm going to avoid world war
iii i'm going to stave it off through my
genius state statesmanship and diplomacy
and basically what he was using
the reason he talked about ukraine at
the top of the speech was he knew that
people were going to tune out eventually
and he he wanted to avoid talking about
what he was actually doing at home
because it was such a failure so he just
basically gave a news report on what was
happening in in ukraine but the
situation is growing worse there day by
day and biden is doing absolutely
nothing off to stab to stave off what
could be potentially a much larger
potentially nuclear
war did you like that clip i'm so glad
you know we're entering into a
penitential season right now and and one
thing that i would recommend giving up
for lent
would be all the other podcasts other
than mine
you obviously you should continue to
listen to my podcast but you could give
up all of the other ones and then you'll
have time to listen to more of my
episodes which you can get at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
type in the michael nola show subscribe
leave a five star review obviously ring
the bell here we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you